my expectations for trader means to be
honest is pretty low so I don't think
these are traditional that's not a thing
that you couldn't find right I don't
know it looks a little funky well so not
a hundred percent sure what this is this
is it's really bad
hey I'm Jenny and jasmine
hi I'm Rochelle hi I'm Stanley and we're
Asian and we're gonna be trying
agent booth from Trader Joe's or means
we just got a weird because do you think
that they would go with something like
trader Jing so they could keep the TJ's
oh no no I'm half Taiwanese half Korean
and my cousins are half Taiwanese half
Japanese so I have a lot of like
interation culture in my life I am
chinese-american my family is originally
from China where I grew up it was a
predominately like Asian American
community so I grew up eating lots and
lots and lots of like great Asian food
I'm half Indian and half Filipino and I
grew up eating a lot of random different
types of Asian foods I'm
chinese-american as well my parents grew
up in either South China at the Hong
Kong Hirsch area and then I actually
grew up in Louisiana I did go eating a
lot of Chinese food with like a Cajun
twist but it was also mostly our own
restaurants so my favorite place to get
my family's traditional Filipino food
would be at the holiday parties all my
auntie's they all make great dishes and
they'll bring them my favorite place to
go for Chinese food are really like the
mom-and-pop shops then you know this
place is like really good cuz they are
like a specialty place originally I'm
from Orange County and we have a lot of
bombs how many's food there so I always
go back from like every weekend just to
get it usually like grandma's is like
come on it's grandma's cooking you can't
go wrong I love to Joe's Asian food what
is on it in college when I didn't have
any Asian markets nearby I am at Trader
Joe's at least once and not twice a week
I'm not gonna say it's like the most
traditional but I'm not the best person
to maybe put in this because if it's
edible I'll like it and my expectations
for Trader means to be honest it's
pretty low it's a bad that I already
know that this is the frozen Japanese
fried rice I don't need to try it I like
it
that does look really good it's got like
pieces of norian
mm-hmm edamame what's the black surface
yeah like a weave but this does not look
like seaweed this looks like a leaf of
some kind I'm not sure if it's like the
most authentic Japanese fried rice but
it's really good I can eat a whole bag
in one sitting
that's seaweed oh that's really good
mm-hmm Trader Joe's doesn't writes
really well do you even find seaweed and
fried rice often no because usually when
you get fried rice you'll have like a
little bit of scrambled egg you might
have some like peas you might have some
like carrots some ham but this has got
like edamame and like little bits of
seaweed that's not a thing that you put
in fried rice usually there's like a
right amount of like soy flavor in there
what I like is that they don't rely on
soy sauce just to make it fried rice
because I think a lot of people make
fried rice wrong when they're just like
oh sorry yeah but I eat this again I
don't know that I would because to me I
feel like when I want to eat fried rice
I want like a good mix of stuff like I
want some ham I want some like crunch
from the carrots and it's mostly just
like rice and that seaweed thing yeah I
don't think I would you just going to
use it
I like the tiny chunks of things this is
very good to just eat when you're in
college yeah or even know I didn't even
know Trader Joe's had this I'll probably
go get some oh my god they have so many
other common General Tso's chicken or
something
oh I was like is this just really sad
orange chicken it looks I mean it might
be orange chicken - but it's like fried
chicken leg it looks soggy any crunch
that is intended is gone except the
orange chicken oh yeah I know it looks a
little funky no it looks great it's
tangy and I don't mean to put it in my
mouth you I just know what it is you
already know let's see how I'm gonna get
a smaller piece and that's super excited
about it hmm
oh yeah yeah
all right if I could spit this out I
would mmm the texture of the chicken is
still really moist the outside you can
get that crunch from the fry and the
tankyness from the sauce is there and it
doesn't overwhelm the flavor of the
chicken it seems like it's trying to do
the dehorning sauce but there's not
enough like sauce yeah I had my doubts
at first cuz it doesn't look that great
it actually the flavors pretty good and
I had compared this against pan Express
like just give pan Express all my money
this is it's really bad okay sorry
nothing can really be penalized this is
still really good like I again I've
spent hundreds of dollars on this item
I'm not sure about eat this again I
would probably like do my own stuff to
like make it better than what it once
was yeah it was pretty good I would buy
it I love me some Bao Bao in any shape
or form is great so I'm pretty stoked on
it I'm just gonna go for it yeah
butthese almost with the class I call
them my ba Bay's which in mandarin means
my babies
you need your babies Oh like this it's a
decent size for a bun thank God like the
police that you would see when you go to
like dim sum and you order these buns
but what's kind of weird is that like
usually when you see this plate just
because they've actually like done it
and wrapped it and this is just like
it's shaved off yeah yeah it's like
really hard is yours have like okay so I
don't think these are traditional and
you know at all from what they tried to
do it's not bad the filling is not bad I
feel like it's a different color right
it's supposed to be barbecue pork inside
with a little bit of a reddish color you
can see that it's like varnish so it
doesn't like them look like a
traditional bow being a microwaveable
bow it's really not that bad once you
bite in towards the middle and you hit
one of these like little pleats it gets
really cute usually when you want to eat
this bun it's like really soft and
fluffy if I didn't have any agents that
around me and I got this I'd be static
there's a lot of Chinese influence in
Filipino culture as well in terms of
food flavor-wise I think it's pretty
great I grew up eating these Filipinos
love Bao the buns themselves to me they
always remind me of just going to like
Sunday done some of my
and honestly this is a decent version of
that my only concern is that there's a
lot of dough on this side and the meat
is like on that side so like sometimes
you'll just get a giant and doughy by
what I eat this again
yes actually I would go to Trader Joe's
and buy this if I was like really
craving a bun and I couldn't get to dim
sum if my mom tried that she probably
think Oh a few dollars not bad so much
better than doing all this way I mean
out of like a 1 through 5 scale this is
definitely like a solid 3 yeah that's
good
good job 60% mm-hmm solid F wah this is
really boring
oh okay full disclosure I'm not a fan of
matcha but well I'm also not 100% sure
this is this like matcha milk or
something maybe it's like a matcha milk
tea it smells like matcha all right here
we go
oh yeah yeah yeah it's really good this
is the only item I haven't had yeah I've
never had this I also didn't grow up
drinking this but I would definitely buy
this it's good reminds me of when you go
to like a Japanese restaurant and then
they have like that like green tea ice
cream at the end but it's melted and
it's war matcha is very trendy yeah
really is there's like all matcha tea
shops that's actually where I'm not
liking it I've never been to those I'm
sorry yeah and you can get it with
different milks oh yeah this tastes like
a dessert which is like how I like all
my drinks it'll be good iced yeah I'd be
great ice what I drink this again I uh
no no I mean I don't know maybe I'm not
the biggest watch of Fame to begin with
to but also something like hot milk yeah
I don't know maybe this is the new oat
milk guy I don't I don't think I'm
maturing this together
rice was surprising for me I thought it
was pretty good the matcha as well and I
was not surprised by the orange chicken
I'm nice hating on Trader Joe's for
trying but personally I don't think I
would buy it yeah I was actually
surprised by how good the fried rice was
and the matcha as well but to be fair
you know what I think anytime that you
have like prepackaged food that's
supposed to be something else like
something normal that you would get
fresh it's never gonna be as good as
like the real deal if you're in a place
where you can't buy
the authentic Asian markets I would say
these items from Trader Joe's are a
great place to start we're not saying
that they're the most traditional and
most authentic Indian foods but they're
still very good
[Music]
you